[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and welcome
to episode number 122
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I'm Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
Hi, Melanie.
How are you doing?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm doing OK.
MARK MANDEL: I'm doing OK.
Before we get
started today, I know
you and I wanted to just
have a little personal note
to talk about the recent
incident at YouTube
in San Bruno.
MELANIE WARRICK: We wanted to
acknowledge that that happened.
And just a side note
on that, usually
we record our interviews
and our wrappers,
as we like to call them, a
couple of days out before we
launch our podcast on Wednesday.
So we had recorded
last week's prior.
But yeah, we wanted
to acknowledge
what happened and also the
fact that, obviously, these
are some serious issues
that are going on in the US,
as well as at other locations.
And we want to give our support
to our YouTube colleagues
and those who've been impacted.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
And just as a reminder.
If you need any sort of mental
health help, please reach out.
There are plenty of resources.
We'll put some in the
show notes, as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: And we're
also grateful for the support
that the community has been
showing to the YouTubers,
as well.
There's a lot of great people--
MARK MANDEL: Companies
MELANIE WARRICK: --images and
things that have been shared.
But yes, mental
health is a big issue.
There's a significant amount of
stigma that's still out there,
but there's some great resources
and support that's coming out.
And we highly recommend people
reach out if they need help.
OK.
So Mark, this week we have
actually a podcast interview
that I'm excited about,
because we got a chance
to bring in some of the folks
from Project Jupyter, Jessica,
Yuvi, and Chris, who
are all here to talk
to us about Project Jupyter.
And specifically, we
dive into JupyterHub,
as well as Binder, and
just get into the mechanics
and the support around that.
And this is a tool or tools
that are being used specifically
around the research, but they're
not just for researchers.
So you'll hear more
about that shortly.
MARK MANDEL: Then
after that, as always,
we do our question of the week
where we're talking about how
did Google predictions do during
March Madness, which I believe
is basketball.
I'm pretty sure.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yeah, I love it.
You're the gamer,
but yet neither of us
really know that much about
sports outside of that.
MARK MANDEL: No.
MELANIE WARRICK: Anyway, OK,
so cool things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Let's
start with your favorite.
MARK MANDEL: OK, yeah.
So this was actually a couple of
weeks ago, but is really cool.
If you hadn't known,
there's a new Dragon Ball Z
game coming out that's hosted
on Google Cloud Platform.
I'm going to put a
link in the show notes
to the video they did at the
Game Developer Conference
presentation, they did at
the Google Developer Day,
where they talk
about how they use
Spanner for global consistency,
as well as the Google Network
to enable player-versus-player
action around the world.
They show a live demo
of someone playing
in San Francisco against
someone in Japan,
which is really, really
cool, with really low latency
and a really great
real-time gameplay.
MELANIE WARRICK: And one
of the other cool things
that they're using is BigQuery
to help do their analysis,
which I think is great.
But it is, it's pretty
impressive in terms
of being able to
use Spanner as a way
to connect all the
different players out there.
Next cool thing of the week
that we want to mention
is text-to-speech, which is
powered by DeepMind's WaveNet.
So text-to-speech is a new API
that has been developed and is
out there now on
Google Cloud Console
that you can use to basically
convert text to speech.
And they have 32 different
voices from 12 languages.
The nice thing is that
it's running on TPU,
so it takes one second of
speech and can convert it
in 50 milliseconds.
It's got much higher
fidelity, higher quality.
This WaveNet model
that they're using
is actually something
that was initially
developed and
provided back in 2016,
but it's been significantly
improved since then
and used for things
like text-to-speech.
So check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
And finally, a project that
I'm actually a huge fan of,
GitLab--
if you've ever used
it-- a great DevOps
lifecycle tool, as
well as a great place
to host Git for, say, in-studio
or in-company projects.
I've used GitLab in the
past, but I've never actually
been exposed so much to
their continuous integration
and continuous delivery
pipeline tooling.
But it just got even better
in that they have a new order
DevOps feature, which detects
the language your app is
written in and automatically
builds your CI and CD pipelines
for you.
And particularly of note is
that it can now push really
nicely up to Kubernetes, either
a GKE cluster or an existing
Kubernetes cluster
in a great way
that works for
continuous delivery.
So it's got some great
tools in it-- super
happy with what GitLab's doing.
MELANIE WARRICK: OK,
Mark, I think it's time
to go talk to the group
from Project Jupyter.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
Let's do it.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So this week, we're
excited to have with us several
members of the team, Project
Jupyter.
We've got Jessica Forde, Yuvi
Panda, and Chris Holdgraf.
Welcome.
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: Yeah,
it's great to be here.
JESSICA FORDE: Hi.
YUVI PANDA: Hi.
MELANIE WARRICK: So I would
like you all to take a minute
and just explain
a little bit more
of what you do on
Project Jupyter.
So Jess, why don't you start?
JESSICA FORDE: So my
name is Jessica Forde.
I've been with Project Jupyter
for a little less than a year.
And I work on a
number of projects.
I'm actually cross-project.
So I've been working a lot
with the JupyterHub team
with Yuvi and Chris.
And then I also do a lot of my
work on the blog, the website.
And I also work on
JupyterLab, which
is our new imagination
of what communication
can be like with Jupyter
Notebook-like interfaces.
And so we just recently
announced that, as well.
You guys can look at that.
We're probably not going be
talking as much about that,
but JupyterLab is also
another project of ours.
We have actually a
number of projects,
and so I end up working
on a lot of them.
YUVI PANDA: Hi.
My name is Yuvi.
I work at UC Berkeley right
under technical operations
for the date science division.
I'm also part of
Project Jupyter.
I've been contributing with
them for about two years.
I mostly work on
scalability stuff.
So that's JupyterHub, BinderHub.
I run the big
JupyterHubs that Berkeley
uses for both
their local classes
and their online classes.
And I also do operations for
BinderHub on mybinder.org.
And then I also develop a lot
of the Kubernetes integrations
for both [? Shipper Hub ?] and
related projects like Dask.
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: Yeah, my
name is Chris Holdgraf.
I'm a fellow over at
the Berkeley Institute
for Data Science.
And I've been in the open source
data analytic world in Python
for several years
now and have sort of
bumped up against the
Jupyter world over that time.
Now I work on the
Jupyter project
as a link between the
technical developments
and some of the specific
use cases and organizations
that use Jupyter technology--
so just a little bit of
this, a little bit of that
and making sure that the things
that we're building in Jupyter
are matching on to
needs that people
have in the scientific and
the education community.
MELANIE WARRICK: So you've all
talked about what you work on.
Can you talk to us a
little bit about what
is Project Jupyter and a
little bit about its history?
Where did it come from?
Because I know IPython
Notebooks originated
as one of the main
projects, but can you
tell us a little more
about all of this?
JESSICA FORDE: Well,
OK, I'll start.
So back in, I think,
Colorado, there
was a physicist
named Fernando Perez,
who was working on his PhD.
And he wanted to be able to
share his research with his
colleagues back
home in Medellín,
Columbia and was frustrated by
the fact that the software he
was working with
was very expensive,
and was closed source, and he
couldn't necessarily share it
very easily with
people back home.
And so he, in his
spare time, created
IPython, which is a project
that still exists today
and is part of the
Jupyter ecosystem.
And IPython is a command line
tool for interactive Python.
It is now considered what
we call a kernel for people
to actually write code
in many other languages.
In fact, you can even
create your own kernel.
We just showed a blog
post with kernels in C++.
So if you want to do interactive
C++, we have interactive C++.
And from there, we got
more people involved.
We have, as part
of our team also,
Brian Granger, who
also leads the project.
And this eventually
became IPython Notebooks,
which is a tool in the
browser for interactive Python
visualization data
science, which
now became renamed to Jupyter.
Because again, we are actually
a polyglot open source project.
And so we now, from
there, have a number
of projects related to
interactive computing,
open source, open
standards, and data science,
and scientific
communication, which
relate to education and
lots of other applications.
And so some of our
latest projects,
Binder and JupyterHub, come out
of that sort of origin story.
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: Yeah, the only
other thing I'd add to that
is that, as the technology
has grown in its complexity
and the variety of uses,
also the organization,
Jupyter itself, has
grown quite a bit.
So as Jessica
mentioned, it originated
with a couple of
developers on extra side
projects kind of
time, but now is
a much more complex and
diversified group of people,
some of which are researchers
at universities, some of which
are data scientists or
developers at companies,
and many of which are
just general open source
enthusiasts who spend their
time working on these projects.
So there are some core
members of the project,
but it has a much broader
open source community that
represents both data analytics
worlds, like Python, or R,
or something like this, but
also a much broader spectrum
of languages, like
C++, or JavaScript,
or anything else
you could imagine.
MARK MANDEL: Jessica,
you mentioned
a couple of times the term
"interactive notebook"
as part of the Jupyter Project.
What exactly does that mean?
JESSICA FORDE: So an
interactive notebook
is a browser interface in
which a person can enter code.
In this example,
we'll take Python.
And so let's say you are a
data scientist writing Python,
and you have your
Pandas dataframe,
and you want to be
able to visualize it.
Now if you wanted to be able
to get the visualization on it,
you probably would have to do
a little bit of extra leg work
to get the image out, to save
it, to open it up and see it.
Whereas, in an
interactive notebook,
things flow together
relatively seamlessly so that,
if you want to create
the plot, the plot
shows up in the browser.
And so we really try to leverage
the power of the browser
to make scientific communication
a part of scientific computing.
MARK MANDEL: Is this
something that I would use
standalone just myself?
Or is this something I would
do in partnership with, say,
another developer kind
of Google Doc style?
Or how does that flow work?
JESSICA FORDE: You
could do it either way.
And in fact, people
do do it either way.
Communication in a
I write something,
and then I send it
to you or share it
to you is very, very popular.
People also use notebooks
to write Scratch.
Say you're trying
to prototype an idea
and you want to be able
to figure out if it runs
or if you like the way
the output looks to you,
you can do it that way.
But additionally,
we actually are
very interested in ideas
of real-time collaboration,
as well.
Today, that's
something that we're
working on and thinking about
in the Jupyter Lab project.
Additionally, you can
communicate to people
within a certain ecosystem,
for example, within JupyterHub.
So these kinds of relationships
between communicating
for yourself and communicating
with other people
are very important to us.
YUVI PANDA: So also, people
use it just with GitHub.
So GitHub has
millions of notebooks.
So people use it just like code.
And GitHub even renders
them automatically now.
So that's another way to use it.
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: I think one
of the interesting origin
stories of the Jupyter
Notebook actually comes
from scientific publishing.
So one of the original ideas
that the then IPython, now
Jupyter team had was
trying to find a way
to package the
static representation
of your work, which in
science and academia
is just basically a PDF.
It's a snapshot of
words that you write
and static images
that you generate.
But behind those
static images is
a lot of really
interesting complexity.
And in some sense,
that's the real work.
Like, the code and the
operationalization of that code
is where the rubber meets
the road, so to speak.
And so one of the goals of
the original notebook format
was to create an interface and
a way of packaging your work so
that you didn't
have to separate out
the code from the narrative.
And that, hopefully, would
create different ways
that you might try to
communicate your results
to other people in ways that
are only possible when you can
actively be interacting with
whatever work it is that you're
presenting to someone.
JESSICA FORDE: And
we've been really lucky,
in that we've had
very good uptake
from the scientific community,
from the academic community.
I think they're in the
millions of Jupyter
Notebooks available on GitHub.
In fact, it's now considered
a language on GitHub.
Although I don't
know necessarily--
[LAUGHTER]
--if we think of it
as a language, per se,
because Jupyter Notebook can be
written in any kind of language
that we support.
And we support tens of
languages, like over 100,
at least.
And so we have notebooks
from the chief economist
of the World Bank
that are on GitHub.
We have notebooks from the
LIGO Project, which recently
won the physics Nobel Prize,
that are available on GitHub
that we also host on Binder.
So there are a lot of
different interesting stuff
that's being happening.
I know media companies now are
sharing their data journalism
through Jupyter Notebooks.
And so we're really
excited about the ways
people have been
able to use it today.
MELANIE WARRICK: Now you've
mentioned JupyterHub.
Can you explain to us a little
bit more about what that is?
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: Yeah, sure.
So a Jupyter
Notebook, for example,
assumes that you're
running something locally
on your own computer.
That's the most common
pattern of interaction
when you're writing code and
running it against some kernel.
What JupyterHub does
is it allows you
to post, either on hardware
that you own or somewhere
in the cloud, a server that
manages multiple Jupyter
processes at the same time.
So it will use a Jupyter
server to have many users
simultaneously sending
code to kernels
and getting the
responses back from them.
It's useful partially because,
as a deployer of a JupyterHub,
you can specify the environment
that you want everyone
to have access to.
You can specify the
packages, the versions.
You can specify data that needs
to be in a particular place
so that everyone
has access to it.
And the goal there is that,
by standardizing these things,
you're creating a more
consistent environment so
that people can share
their work more easily,
and you don't run into
strange conflicts that
come from having the
wrong package installed
or having the incorrect
version of data
on some path on your computer.
And the other hope is that you
can use this, I should say,
as a portal to shared computing
infrastructure so that people
who don't have, say, fancy,
sophisticated hardware
themselves, or
maybe who don't even
have a laptop with a
ton of RAM, can still do
fairly complicated processing.
But they're doing
so via the cloud
or via whatever resources the
JupyterHub is deployed on.
And so I think the goal
there is that it increases
the accessibility towards
doing modern-day data
analytic interactive
workflows in a way
that's only possible
when you have
those kind of shared resources.
MELANIE WARRICK: And when
we were talking earlier,
you were saying
how JupyterHub was
sort of the impetus for
why you started to engage
with using Kubernetes.
YUVI PANDA: So when I
started working at Berkeley,
we had a biggish course.
We had like-- what?
900 students at that time?
They were learning
fundamental data science.
And we wanted them
to use a JupyterHub,
because we didn't want to
spend our time teaching
people how to install stuff.
And they might have
different kinds of computers.
And then someone's going to
come up with the Windows XP,
and we had to figure out how
to install Python through that.
So we wanted to eliminate
that, and then allows
students to focus directly
on learning data science.
This is also
especially important
because we were
targeting groups that
were not just in
computer science,
but people from other
disciplines and whatnot.
And it was like we were
running into some scaling
problems at that time.
And we also wanted to be as
cloud-agnostic as possible.
We did not want to get locked
into any specific cloud vendor.
And we also wanted to be able
to [INAUDIBLE] if we needed to.
And so at this point, Kubernetes
was a very good choice for us
to make because it let us do
all of this in one system.
So we didn't need to have like
Ansible or something else that
set up the base
system, and then have
like a clustering
technology on top which was
a lot more complex to manage.
This was just like, OK, we
have a Kubernetes cluster,
we can do everything
we want on top of it.
And the scalability is
[? fatly ?] elastic.
You can go up and down
without too many problems.
And so we were like,
OK, let's just--
I was already writing
the Cumulus integration
for JupyterHub for a
while as a volunteer.
And then I just got hired at
Berkeley to do that full time.
MARK MANDEL: So does
that mean that you
have to have a Kubernetes
cluster to run JupyterHub?
Or is it an optional thing?
YUVI PANDA: Not necessarily.
So JupyterHub is
very extensible.
You can plug in any
authenticator you want.
And then, the same way, you can
plug in any spawner you want.
So it ships with
a default spawner
that just doesn't
assume anything,
except you have
the next machine.
But then there are spawners
for lots of popular technology.
The spawners just use a
docker or a container.
There's the Kubernetes
Spawner that we have written.
And then there's a
system despawner.
There's lots of spawners.
People write them.
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: I think
one of the challenges
that Data 8 faced
in particular is
that, when you're designing
technology for something
like science or education,
you have to make assumptions
that the organizations
that are going
to be using that
technology don't have,
oftentimes, as much resources
and funds to hire people
as you would if you were at a
company or something like this.
And I think one of the
benefits of Kubernetes
is that, because of the
properties that people often
talk about in terms
of self-healing,
and scalability,
and stuff like this,
you can often manage more
complex deployments with fewer
highly-trained, technical,
DevOps-style people.
And Data 8, as Yuvi mentioned,
now it's over, I think,
1,400 students or
something like this.
And it has, by some accounts,
a relatively modest team
of people who are actively
developing it, and upgrading
it, and maintaining
it over time.
And my intuition is
that that's something
that would be much
more difficult to do
if you were using other kinds
of cloud deployment approaches.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
I know when we first
were talking about doing
this podcast, Jessica,
you were telling
me about Binder.
And I know Binder is
built off of JupyterHub.
So can you tell us a little more
about Binder, and what it does,
and why it was built?
JESSICA FORDE: Yeah, so I'll
start with the story of Binder.
So Binder originally
started as a project
that was out of Janelia Farm.
And it was a project to share
notebooks in a curated manner
so that you had
notebooks that had
a similar idea or a
similar narrative story
to come together in
one cohesive piece.
And so the current
set-up we have now is
the version 2.0 of Binder, which
is a publicly-available service
for GitHub repos to share
with the public in a way that
has the entire environment
set up so that you would go
to a specific URL, and you are
launched in a docker container,
and that ends up giving
you the opportunity
to work with the
repo with everything
already pre-installed.
It's a similar experience to the
things that the Data 8 students
are getting.
But in this case, you are
getting specifically the repo
that you are looking
at it from GitHub.
And this is particularly
interesting for applications
in science, and
education, also people
who are creating new libraries
and want to show it off.
In fact, that's what we
used to show off JupyterLab.
We ended up using
Binder and said,
if you want to try
out JupyterLab, here.
We have it right now.
You just click on
the URL, and you
are taken to the user
interface of JupyterLab.
You don't need to
install anything.
Here it is.
Play with it.
See how you like it.
So that's particularly
interesting for us,
because it's a different way for
us to interact with the public,
providing open source
as a service for us
to share scientific data science
repositories through GitHub.
And in fact, Binder is
actually a number of projects
that are connected together.
There are modular pieces.
JupyterHub is
actually one of them.
And the other major pieces
under it are repo to Docker,
the binder server itself.
And then we also have front
ends such as Jupyter Notebooks,
RStudio and JupyterLab.
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: It's
worth highlighting
that Binder was originally
created by a researcher named
Jeremy Freeman.
And it was also open
source technology.
It was running
online in the cloud.
And it performed
what Jessica just
described-- being able to
share an interactive data
analytic environment
with a single link.
And because that
project was open source,
the Jupyter team started having
conversations with the first
incarnation of the
Binder project,
basically realizing that
a lot of the complexity
of the tooling in Binder
1.0-- we'll call it--
was doing a lot of this
stuff that JupyterHub
handles very flexibly
and very nicely already.
And so there was kind of a
realization that, well, what
if we could just make Binder
a particular configuration
of a deployment of
a JupyterHub and add
one extra component, which is
the ability to automatically
generate your computing
environment on-the-fly so
that people can specify
their environment just
via random text files in
their GitHub repository,
rather than requiring
people to craft a Docker
image on their own?
So those projects
kind of fused together
in a collaboration that's
been going on for about a year
or so now.
But a lot of that initial
heavy lifting we're
all very thankful to the
original Binder team for.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And I know, when
we were talking about
Binder, the reason
behind driving out, building
up Binder 2-- or part
of the reason-- was you've
got so much great content
and research that's being done
in the scientific community,
and there was a desire to
be able to make it easier
for people to run
that kind of content
and run that without having
to recreate it from scratch.
JESSICA FORDE: Yeah,
I mean, I think
that one of the points of
friction in scientific research
is being able to
reproduce or being
able to work with the scientific
computation pipeline that
is in a particular paper.
So for example, the
LIGO Project is probably
our most famous
research institute
who has their research
available on Binder.
They have a demo
that allows people
to get immediate access
to their data, which
is gravitational wave data,
and show people basic signal
processing methods so that
you can reproduce their study
and basically find the
gravitational waves that they
got the Nobel Prize for.
If people did not necessarily
have access to Binder,
it would be less interactive.
One would have to figure out how
the dependencies were set up,
install everything from scratch,
and try to piece together
all the different
parts of the repo
to understand how to reproduce
this result. Whereas,
with Binder and also
Jupyter Notebooks,
it becomes a seamless,
interactive notebook that
has everything pre-installed.
And so you can walk yourself
through the thinking
of these scientists
and understand how they
conduct their own research.
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: Yeah.
The way that I like
to think about this
is there is, in my mind, a
difference between making
your work technically
open and reproducible,
versus making it practically
open and reproducible.
And a lot of times, you'll
see people just throw
a bunch of code and
maybe some description
of the environment
needed to run that code
onto the web somewhere.
And while it is
technically possible
that you could go through all
of the different steps of trying
to figure out what it is that
was going through the author's
head when they put
all of this there,
the vast majority
of people aren't
going to take the time
to clone a repository,
pull it onto their computer,
install all the packages that
are needed, get the data
into the right place,
spin up their own session,
start sifting through it,
debug problems
when they come up.
Most people just won't do that.
But if you could do
something like share
the ability to interact
with that repository just
via a single link that someone
clicks and they can immediately
start getting up and
running, I think the barrier
to entry there is low enough
that people will actually
start doing it.
And then you can do
different kinds of things
in terms of designing
your content,
when you're assuming
that others are going
to be interacting with it.
JESSICA FORDE: And we
recently presented some work
at the Fairness,
Accountability and Transparency
Conference in New
York with regards
to accountability and
transparency in machine
learning research,
although we believe
this extends to all different
kinds of scientific research
and data science in general.
But the interesting
distinction, I think,
in when we think
about what Binder does
is that, historically
when people were thinking
about reproducibility,
they wanted
to be able to
independently validate
what happened in
a scientific study
doing it in their own laboratory
or their own environment.
We're basically trying to
replicate the environment
of the scientist,
as much as possible
with modern
computational methods,
so it is as if the
laboratory is opening
the doors to the public, and
allowing people to walk in,
and says, these are our tools.
This is what we did.
And you can use these tools
as if they were your own.
So it's kind of an
interesting distinction.
And I think that's
part of the reason why
we think about it even as an
accountability and transparency
project.
Because the
distinction is actually
that you're not
necessarily reproducing it
in that, if it's not
a separate thing,
it is the exact same environment
as the scientist that
is producing this research.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
This sounds really great.
So if I'm sitting down and
I'm doing some research,
and I have this data set
that I'm doing research on,
and I'm thinking to myself, I
want to get this out on Binder,
where do I put my data?
What does that development
pipeline look like?
How do I get that
sort of thing set up?
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: So one
of the goals of Binder
is to try and piggyback
on pre-existing tools
in the open source ecosystem
as much as possible.
And what that means is that
the delta, the amount of energy
that's needed to make a
repository, quote unquote,
"Binder ready" is pretty small.
What Binder does is, when
you give it a URL to a Git
repository-- and that could be
something on GitHub, or GitLab,
or wherever you put your
code-- as long as it's
publicly available, it's going
to check out the repository.
And it looks for what are
called configuration files.
And by that, what
I mean is if you're
a Python developer,
requirement.txt or
environment.yml, if
you're Julia developer,
a capital REQUIRE file.
It also looks for things
like apt.txt files
to specify apt packages.
And the goal of this is to
infer the environment that's
needed from text
files that are already
part of the workflows for people
from those various communities.
And so, from the
author's perspective,
if you want to make your
repository interactive
via something like
Binder, all you need to do
is make sure that those
text files are there
in either the root
of your repository
or in a folder in the root
of your repo called Binder.
Binder is then just going
to automatically look
through those files.
And whenever it finds them, it
generates a Docker file that
says, OK, I need this
version of NumPy installed
and this version of
Matplotlib installed.
It then generates a Docker
image from that Docker file
and registers it online.
And then Binder knows how to
ask for certain images based
on the links that different
users are clicking on.
So in many cases, you don't
actually have to do anything.
If you've already
followed best practices
in scientific computing,
you've already
included an environment.yml
file with your repository.
In many cases,
all you need to do
is just give that URL to
Binder, and it'll do the rest.
MARK MANDEL: And where
do I put my data?
Especially if I have
very large sets of data,
where does that go?
Does it go on my
GitHub repository?
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: I think that if
you asked 10 different people,
you would get 10 different
responses to that.
[LAUGHTER]
JESSICA FORDE: The examples
that we've seen so far
generally use
smaller sets of data,
just because the amount of
computational power we have
is rather limited.
So the work that
we've done so far
on showing how people can use
Binder has been on projects
where the size of the
data is relatively limited
and the amount of computation
that a person is finally using
at the tail end is limited.
So we won't necessarily
be able to reproduce
on Binder a study that
uses an entire server
farm, for example.
But if you do have these pieces
and parts, the computation
then, since it is
interactive, can be modified.
So for example, in the write-up
we had for the Fairness,
Accountability and
Transparency study,
we took a [? HKai ?] paper
that had relatively simple
experiments computationally.
They weren't expensive.
And we said, OK, let's try
modifying this experiment
and seeing how this
works, which is actually
very interesting because, in a
lot of studies, you are given,
this is what we did.
It's done.
There it is.
But the way Binder
works, because it
uses interactive computing and
it has the same environment,
it says, now that you have this
tool, this model, this idea,
we give you the
ability to interact
with the research in a way
that people haven't been
able to do online in a
publication-like experience,
which is particularly
interesting, I think,
because it allows people to
be able to think beyond what
the researchers are
simply telling you
and work with the repo in
a way that you might want
to be able to work
with it on your own,
that you necessarily
weren't able to do it
because it required so much
leg work to get to that point.
MELANIE WARRICK: But
is it built to be
able to work with server farms?
I mean, is it built
to be able to hook
into that kind of thing?
YUVI PANDA: Yeah.
It ultimately uses JupyterHub
to actually run your code.
And JupyterHub can hook
into anything you want.
At least right
now, because we've
done it as a free
public service,
we put limits on how much RAM
you can use and all of that.
But you can set up one for your
own institution or whatever,
and then give it
as much resources
as you want running on
whatever kind of infrastructure
you need.
So you could, for example,
just configure your JupyterHub
to use--
I think there is a
Google Cloud VM spawner.
So then everyone basically
gets one entire machine.
Or you can just configure
it to, like, OK, everyone
gets an instance group that can
scale up and down as they want.
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: Yes.
JESSICA FORDE: And then
to your question, Mark,
you can integrate with any
kind of data repositories
that exist out there.
YUVI PANDA: Yeah.
Yeah.
It's just a matter of
what you do in your code.
I know, for example, there
is the Pangea Project there.
And that's a funded
project that tries
to make a central platform for
people who do Earth sciences.
And so they store all their data
in GCS, Google Cloud Storage.
And so they have fuse drivers
that let them get data directly
from GCS.
And the UK Met Office
has something similar.
But they're an S3, so they
get their data out of S3.
And this is all
agnostic to JupyterHub.
We don't actually
care how we do this.
JESSICA FORDE: Actually, also,
one of the earliest users
of JupyterHub for scientific
computing and research
is actually the labs in
the Department of Energy.
They end up doing a lot of
high-performance computing.
And they have a
lot of scientists
who aren't DevOps people,
who aren't necessarily
the most sophisticated when it
comes to running complex jobs.
And they want to be able
to have as lightweight
of an experience as possible.
And JupyterHub was a
really great way for them
to have access to really
powerful Jupyter Notebooks.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Is this only meant
for scientific communities?
Or have you seen
use cases outside?
YUVI PANDA: So, I
don't think it's only
meant for scientific computing.
So I came into this
from Wikimedia,
and so it's like a very,
oh, free knowledge.
Everyone should be
able to participate.
And so I was, at that time,
helping run this thing
called Two Labs,
which is we provide
free compute for people
who want to do things
with Wikimedia data.
So for example, a lot of the
anti-vandalism bots run here.
A lot of the statistics
are run here.
But we required people do
[? SSI chain ?] and then
use Grid Engine.
And that was complex.
It was excluding
a lot of people.
So from our perspective
at the time, we were like,
we wanted more people to
be able to access our data
and do things with it.
And so a good solution
was JupyterHub.
So that's where I
actually started work
on the Kubernetes stuff, because
we had a Kubernetes cluster.
And we're like, OK, let's
put JupyterHub on this
so we can securely provide
access to our data to people.
So we provided
access to our dumps
but even to our direct MySQL
database, so which was live.
We redacted all the
sensitive information
and gave people access to that.
And that's something you
cannot do on your own computer,
because that's a data store
that's only available there.
It's really large.
It's updated in real time.
And there's, I think, like
4 million edits or something
that people have made
from that JupyterHub.
So that's, I think,
a very good use case.
And I think there's more
people doing things like that.
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: I think it's
worth highlighting again--
because I think this is actually
related to your previous point,
too--
the goal of the
Jupyter ecosystem
is to build open source
building blocks that
can be composed and
used for whatever use
case you might have in mind.
And so sometimes that is
doing scientific research.
Sometimes that is
teaching a class,
either at the
university level or even
at the elementary school
and middle school levels.
Sometimes it means providing
an interactive environment
to connect with some
resources or hardware that
would otherwise be very
difficult to connect to,
like what Yuvi just described
with the Wikipedia data set.
And related then to your
question about storage,
our goal, the Jupyter
Project's goal,
is not to create completely
tightly integrated full stack
solutions.
Our goal is to build pieces that
can be put together in order
to accomplish some goal.
And so what I would say--
when people ask,
how is JupyterHub
going to handle large-scale
storage, part of my answer
is, well, we don't
really have to.
We just need to
make sure that, when
there is another
open tool that exists
that makes that
possible, that it's
easy to integrate that into
the JupyterHub Binder workflow.
MELANIE WARRICK: Do you have
any features, functionality
that are up-and-coming, that
are in the future of JupyterHub,
Binder, Project
Jupyter, in general?
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: We have lots.
MELANIE WARRICK: Anything
that you want to talk about?
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Lots is good.
YUVI PANDA: So one thing
that we've been working on
is high scale.
So we're trying to get
up to 50,000 active users
at a time, spanning
multiple Kubernetes
clusters and multiple
hubs, but all
[? pressing ?] the user as one.
So that's like one idea.
We put lot of work
into it at the moment.
On the Binder side,
I think something
that we did fairly recently
and it's not super public
is we added RStudio support.
Because I think a lot of
people in the R community,
they prefer using RStudio,
rather than Jupyter Notebooks.
And so we wanted to be able to--
you know, we don't want to force
people to switch tools just
because they want to use us.
So we were like, OK, let's
make this generic enough
so that people can use
RStudio, or whatever else it
is that they want to use.
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: I think
that another interesting
future direction
for development--
Yuvi just described
what would often be
described as scaling outward.
So we're just trying to get
more, and more, and more users
for a given
JupyterHub deployment.
But especially in more
sophisticated data science
teams or in academic
research scientific research,
you do need access to
non-trivial sized data sets.
Or you need access to
high-performance clusters,
and things like this.
And so I think
that there's going
to be a push of development
towards connecting JupyterHub,
or something like Binder, with
more sophisticated hardware
or more sophisticated
cloud infrastructure
for doing computations
and analyzing data
on that hardware.
And I'm excited to see the
different kinds of uses
that people come up with it,
as the ecosystem of tools that
are natively
running in the cloud
continues to develop further.
YUVI PANDA: I also want to say,
one of our biggest new features
is more documentation.
I think it's--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
YUVI PANDA: --a lot
better documented
now than it was six
months to a year ago.
Jessica, Chris, and
[INAUDIBLE],, who's not here,
have been doing a great
job of making sure
that the only information is
not in some chat somewhere
or hidden up in someone's
brain, but written out in ways
that a diverse group of people
can actually understand and be
used in their own contexts.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
What has it been like
working on an open source
project for all of you?
And it sounds like
multiple, in some cases.
YUVI PANDA: I've been working
on open source projects--
I was working on GNOME
when I was like 19.
And I was working at Wikimedia.
So I don't know what
it's like to not
work on an open source project.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm kind of an outlier.
But Jupyter is the
first project that I'm
on that's partially
based in academia.
So that's a little different.
And it's also a much
more smaller project.
When I started
working at Wikimedia,
it was already very big.
MELANIE WARRICK: But
how is it different?
YUVI PANDA: I think,
at a smaller project,
you have more responsibilities
to be kinder to everyone
than you have at
a larger project.
Now, I'm not saying
that it's OK to be mean
to people on a larger project.
But I think if you are
person 40 in a project,
or person 60 in a
project, then you
have more responsibilities
than if you're
person 800 in a project.
If you're person 800, the
culture is already sort of set.
Changing that is going
to be an uphill battle.
And it's going to be hard.
While if you're at a
smaller-person project,
then it's much easier to set.
So if you are not
careful, then you
can set it in ways that
you don't want it to be.
So I think that's the
biggest difference.
There's technical
differences, of course.
When I was at Wikimedia,
I was the 16th person
to join the ops team.
And I was the least
experienced person doing that.
While here, I think, most
people don't have that much ops
knowledge, because they
come through, like us,
like grad students and whatnot.
So that was also a
big difference for me.
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: But I
think, related to that,
from my perspective, one
of the most exciting things
about the Jupyter Project--
and probably open source,
in general-- is that because of
the open nature of the project,
you get a lot more
voices in the room.
And you get a lot
of representation
from different kinds of
background in the room.
So I think it's
amazing that I get
to work on a team of
people, some of which
are heavily ops oriented and
have an incredible background
in Kubernetes, some of
which care about things
like documentation, and
community growth, and the more
social aspects of open
source, some of whom
are more domain scientists
who run analytics in Python
or in R that wouldn't be
able to deploy a Kubernetes
cluster by themselves.
Being able to coordinate that
kind of chaotic, diverse group
of people in a way that
you can create tools that
are truly community-driven
and also available
for all kinds of use cases
is a really satisfying thing
and, in some ways
is, in my mind,
the primary goal of the
academic, and education,
and scientific communities--
creating public goods
that people can then build
on for whatever purpose
they have in mind.
MELANIE WARRICK: How
do you coordinate?
Or how does that
get coordinated?
JESSICA FORDE: I think
that each sub-project
has their own subculture
and their own sub-methods.
And so that largely
determines how it works.
So actually, like, for example,
for me, I belong to, I think,
like five different Jupyter
Project organizations.
A lot of people don't even know
that we have multiple repos.
I think we have over 100.
We have at least five
or six organizations.
So each organization has
their own norms and culture,
but we actually share
the same code of conduct.
So at the higher level,
values, norms, things like that
are shared.
And we have a governance repo.
If you want to spy
on how we work,
it's all available
to the public.
In fact, all our meetings
are available to the public.
We've put them
online on YouTube.
So our big, weekly meetings
are every Tuesday morning,
9:00 AM Pacific.
You can watch us online.
But each individual project,
then, has their own sub-norms.
So for example, there's
a monthly meeting
that we have with the
JupyterHub and Binder group.
JupyterLab meets every week.
And we have a one-hour
meeting once a week.
But some groups just mostly
work through the mailing list
and the issues.
And so it's all a combination
of all these things.
I guess one of the
things that we probably
haven't mentioned enough, that
we probably should say more is,
again, we are an
open source project.
And so anybody can basically
jump in at any time.
And so we really try to do that.
And I think that's
also a lot of what
I do is I basically try to
Tom Sawyer people into saying,
do you like Jupyter?
You can work for us, too.
And basically, I get them
to do my work for me.
But really, it's
something that's
very, very important to us.
In fact, we're having
a community day,
I think, the 25th of
August in New York, which
is a free day for anyone
who wants to show up.
Or if you just want to
show up on the internet,
we will be actively
working on issues
that's community related.
And we follow GitHub's
norms of marking issues
as first issue or help wanted.
So those things are
particularly standard.
But again, the broader other
kinds of implementations
are slightly different
from team to team.
MELANIE WARRICK: And then,
were there any resources
that you wanted to mention in
regards to JupyterHub, Jupyter
Notebook?
We were talking about some of
the classes that are out there.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
where would people
go if they want to learn
about these projects?
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: So I think
that, in terms of the sort
of examples of particular
deployments of JupyterHubs
for particular use cases,
if you go to data8.org--
just data, then the
number 8 dot org--
that is a public-facing
version of Data 8,
which is this major
course at UC Berkeley
that Yuvi has been
working on and that
has driven a lot of the
technical infrastructure,
particularly on the
Kubernetes side of JupyterHub.
There's also mybinder.org
is the public service
version of Binder.
So as Jessica
mentioned, BinderHub
is open source
technology that anybody
could use for whatever
purpose they want
to to deploy a Binder server.
Mybinder.org is a kind of
technical demonstration
and a free public
service where, as a user,
you can begin to
interact with that
and create shareable,
public links for your code
repositories.
And then, from a
developer's standpoint
or from a deployer's
standpoint, the best way
to learn how to deploy
JupyterHub on Kubernetes
is at-- there's a guide
called "Zero to JupyterHub,"
which you can find
at z2jh.jupyter.org.
And on the flip
side, for BinderHub,
there is a guide to deploying
BinderHub on Kubernetes
at binderhub.readthedocs.io.
JESSICA FORDE: Also,
I should probably
mention another project
on the [INAUDIBLE]..
We have repo to Docker, and
that is also under the GitHub
organization JupyterHub.
A lot of the projects
we've been talking about
have been under the GitHub
Organization JupyterHub.
So if you go to
github.com/jupyterhub,
you'll see a number
of our projects.
And repo to Docker
is one of them,
which is also
particularly useful
if you want to
take a GitHub repo
and turn it into a Docker
file or something that
can be easily used and shared
in that kind of format.
MELANIE WARRICK: This is great.
Well, I really appreciate
all of you coming and talking
to us about Project Jupyter,
Jupyter Notebooks, JupyterHub,
and Binder.
Anything else that you wanted
to talk about before we go?
YUVI PANDA: I just want to say,
if you know Kubernetes or want
to learn more about it, then
you should come and talk to us.
Because there's a lot of things
that we're doing on top of it,
and having more people
do that would be great.
And you will have
lots of impact.
And lots of people
will use your stuff.
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: Actually,
one other thing--
a follow-up to your
previous question.
If you just want to get involved
in the community of the Jupyter
community more broadly,
we have a Gitter channel
for pretty much all
of the major projects.
So there's a Binder Gitter
channel and a JupyterHub Gitter
channel.
There's also a Gitter
channel for most
of the other
components that we've
talked about in this interview.
And we're also pretty
closely monitoring
issues, and mailing
lists, and also
a lot of just
community groups that
are scattered across
cities all over the world.
So we try to be as welcoming and
inviting a community as humanly
possible.
And we would love for
whoever is listening
to this to get involved.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, great.
Well, thank you again.
I'm so glad you all were able
to come to join us today.
Thank you.
CHRIS HOLDGRAF: Yeah,
thank you so much.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
again, thank you,
Jessica, Yuvi, and Chris.
We really appreciate you
coming onto the podcast
and telling us all
about Project Jupyter,
telling us about JupyterHub,
and Binder, and all that,
and also just hearing about
how Kubernetes is being
used in the project, as well.
It was fun.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, thanks
so much for joining us--
super interesting
project, really
great to see that kind of
collaborative development
platform getting built
and having people use it.
It's pretty awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And all open source.
Open source is the best.
OK, so--
MARK MANDEL: Question
of the week--
I'm going to ask you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yay!
MARK MANDEL: Yay!
All right, how did
Google's predictions
do during March Madness?
So actually, let's
have some context.
I know March Madness, big
basketball-- there we go--
basketball tournament.
Google Cloud is a sponsor.
And there's a bunch of
machine learning stuff that
was put in place
to see if we could
predict who was going to win
and who was going to lose.
Is that right?
MELANIE WARRICK: That's right.
And there was also a
COWGILL competition
that's been going
on to allow others
to run their own
prediction models
and see how effective they
were in March Madness.
But Google did do its own
separate prediction model
and worked hard at trying
to be able to come up
with real-time predictions, too.
Because during March
Madness, apparently,
during the halftime,
they would take the data
from the first half and
feed it into the model
and come back with predictions
prior to the second half.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
MELANIE WARRICK:
During the Final Four,
there was a couple
of halftime ads
that were even generated
within the "Halftime Show"
to then show what they
thought the predictions were.
And apparently, they
had a prediction
where Loyola versus
Michigan were playing.
And they predicted 29 rebounds.
And they were right.
And then they also predicted
during Villanova and Michigan
that at least 21 three-pointer
attempts would be made.
And the final count was 24.
So anyways, it was
real interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
there's a blog post
that helps give some insights
in terms of how the prediction
model was built. And this is
actually something you would do
with, typically, any kind of
data science project in terms
of figure out what type of
data you need, then building up
the pipeline that you're going
to need to feed the data,
and build out the
model, and train it,
and then deploying
it into production.
And so they had this
model they trained off
of 200,000 discrete files from a
decade of NCAA basketball data.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: They
apparently engineered
over 800 potential
features, and then applied
variance and univariant
statistical tests.
And they built out
their models using
these more standard regression
and classification techniques.
And when the games
were actually playing,
they were updating
their entire game
state every two
seconds and including
all play-by-play data.
And they were
using Cloud Spanner
to help with this
kind of processing
that they needed to do,
as well as BigQuery.
So like I said,
there's a blog post.
We're going to include
that blog post so that you
can see how specifically
they actually engineered
their prediction models,
how it was deployed.
And it'll give you
some great insights
to think about when you're doing
your own type of data analysis,
data prediction modeling.
And yeah, it's kind of cool.
MARK MANDEL: That is cool.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's kind of cool
what the results looked like.
how they built it.
And congrats to the team.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Awesome.
All right, Melanie,
before we wrap up today,
are you going anywhere,
doing anything cool?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, I will
be speaking at Techtonica,
actually, this week on the 11th.
And I'm going to be
talking about AI.
And then actually, this
weekend, on Saturday,
I'm going to be speaking
at the Harker Research
Symposium on the 14th,
participating in a panel
to talk about diversity
and inclusion.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Mark, what about you?
MARK MANDEL: So I'm
not going anywhere,
but I did just start
something really cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, that's sad.
MARK MANDEL: It's fine.
I was very focused on
the [? Aganes ?] launch
and Game Developers'
Conference, which
means I need to wrap back up.
But in the meantime,
I've started
doing something really cool
that I'm really excited about.
MELANIE WARRICK: OK.
MARK MANDEL: I've
started streaming
the work that I'm doing on the
[? Aganes ?] development thing.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: So if you're
into game development
and you're interested in
patterns and strategies
for scaling multi-player
games, it could be interesting.
But if you're into
Kubernetes and you
want to look at cluster resource
definitions, or controllers
or-- on Friday last week, I was
doing some Helm integration,
that kind of stuff.
You might find
interesting, as well.
So we'll put the link
in the show notes,
twitch.tv/markmandel.
I'm doing Tuesdays at 9:00 AM
Pacific on a regular basis,
but also trying to do a lot
of little ad hoc sessions,
as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: You're
doing all kinds of shows now.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's fun.
Actually, streaming coding
is delightfully wonderful.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, that's great.
And as far as I know
it, Mark, you and I
are working on trying
to make sure that we do
an actual interview on Aganes.
So hopefully, that'll be coming
up soon, as soon as we can
sort out some of the logistics.
MARK MANDEL: I
should get on that.
That would be fun.
MELANIE WARRICK: Because
your schedule's pretty busy.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Melanie, thank you
so much for joining me
for yet another podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]